ah here it is
yeah there is a leak so strange you
didn't tell you
that's not really
you know in my experience
husbands don't keep that many things
secret from their wives you know hmm
right
you guys tell each other everything till
death do you part
Ava
how long do you want me to keep this up
oh
you're really gonna make me keep looking
for the fake leak
[Music]
so
here's what I think happened
I think you figured out the whole thing
the booties
the scratches amona all of it
there's no way our sweet Nathan put all
that together himself he's not wired
like us
I think you came up with this
podcast
no idea what you're talking about
okay
here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna give you
one more chance to tell me the truth
because if this
is gonna work if we're gonna move
forward as as partners it's got to be
trust am I right
hey it's me again
just call me when you get this okay he's
still not here I don't know where you
are just just call me
you're late
yeah I brought a friend
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]